the reaction was shocked they chose to
come in and break the door down like
SWAT team style rifles held up you know
the ready and the fingers on the trigger
all that stuff
the police have used force in an
aggressive manner that was not needed
there's no reason for militarized radon
smoke shop on May 7th 2014
this smoke shop in tiny Alpine Texas was
rated by law enforcement for the fourth
time in three years but this time was
different because the DEA was in charge
as part of the Obama administration's
project synergy phase two a national day
of raids meant to take down purveyors of
synthetic drugs who then funnel cash to
Middle Eastern terror groups
Ilana Lipson the purple zones owner a 29
year old Jewish woman and self professed
supporter of Israel was shocked to learn
she was a target of the federal
government but she soon realized there
was local law enforcement that had put
her on the DEA hit list the purple zone
enjoys a loyal following among college
students but as a lightning rod for some
of the town's more culturally
conservative residents you really really
love me and you like what I do or you
really hate me there's no in-between
I've been called the dirty [ __ ]
I've been asked where my horns were I've
been told to go back to joy York I've
had people come into my store and tell
me my store was [ __ ] up that I was
poisoning the youth of the town even
though I have a big sign that says
18-plus I mean the bars here in Alpine
don't even have ID scanners and I have
an ID scanner with a population of a
little more than 5,000 Alpine is quite
literally in the middle of nowhere more
than 200 miles from El Paso and 75 miles
from Mexico making it a natural home for
a great many in law enforcement
including federal agencies like the DEA
and the Border Patrol even Saul Ross
State University the town's signature
institution hosts a law Enforcement
Academy in 2012 the purple zone was
rated by the Alpine PD for the first
time they came looking for evidence that
Alana was selling spice or synthetic
drugs which Alana sells is potpourri in
the incensed section of her store 10 to
12 men like SWAT team style came in
started tearing through everything and
the rest of me I rested my mother so
your mother's never been an employee
here and she's not a co-owner of the
store and she has made no investment in
the store what they arrested her as well
yes and she's still under indictment yes
they claim chemically
that the chemicals are M a.m. 22:01 XLR
11 and PB 22 the chemical makeup of
popery varies by the manufacturer but
these three chemicals were not illegal
in the state of Texas at the time
however the controlled substance
analogue Enforcement Act affords law
enforcement the power to prosecute
possession of substances similar to
controlled substances there is no clear
policy on how one determines whether a
chemical is an analogue of a banned
substance which makes avoiding running
afoul of this law difficult you can buy
these products online you can buy these
products at any gas station any
convenience store I mean all the stuff
that I bought I know was legal it always
came with a lab report you know it's
legal in Texas it was legal federally it
was there was no issue with it was
always marked not for human consumption
lacking the budget for further lab tests
Alpine's District Attorney rod Ponton
went before the Brewster County Board of
Commissioners pleading for thousands of
dollars in additional funding he was
refused out of resources but intent on
proving Alana's criminality he would
find a willing partner in the DEA an
agency without his budget constraints
the Obama administration's projects
energy phase to launch trades all over
the country on May 7th 2014 led by the
DEA and armed with a Brewster County
search warrant members of the Border
Patrol Department of Homeland Security
Brewster County Sheriff's Office and the
Alpine PD stormed the purple zone local
businessman Tom Cochran took pictures of
the scene well when I got there I got
some pictures of the DEA agents actually
coming out I got pictures of the door
that was broken after they left I got
pictures of how they ransacked the
inside and turned off the security
cameras there's broken glass all over
the floor there's blood on the ground
the more one of the agents that
apparently cut himself on his way in
after they'd broken the door down the
next day I also got a picture of Ariel
Lipson injuries as well during the raid
Alana's sister Arielle was placed under
arrest for assaulting a DEA agent who
she claims pinned her to the ground with
the butt of a rifle so I put the
pictures up on Facebook and everything
was fine is about 24 hours and then
everybody kind of flipped out I mean I
was having all kinds of folks relatives
of officers involved people with the
police department all kinds of folks
wanting me to take the pictures down rod
Ponton the district attorney he asked me
to take them down he told me the
pictures were inaccurate and I told them
that you know their pictures they can't
be inaccurate they're just reflections
of what happened there he said I was
being inflammatory and you know I think
that the public's got a right to know
what's
the community days later Alana was
arrested for violating a little-known
federal law prohibiting the purchase of
ammunition while under indictment but
before she could bail herself out of
jail she was presented with a bond
document requiring her to recant
statements she had made to the media
accusing the DEA of assaulting her
sister the document also compelled her
to ask Tom Cochran to remove the photos
of the raid from his Facebook page we
were so shocked he took a picture of it
and put it online so people could
actually see the handwriting of the
officials this is what you're going to
say to get your bond you have the
government forcing someone who they're
trying to prosecute into essentially
confessing before that she before they
can get a bond I mean that's
unconstitutional I before you take them
down and then Alana as soon as she was
released from federal detention she came
immediately to my shop before she'd gone
anywhere else and came up give me a big
hug and thank you for not taking him
down and said that the whole deal was
coerced and she didn't want to have to
sign that they told her she was gonna
sit in jail her business is gonna rot
until she signed the paperwork so she
was really under duress when it happened
still the Border Patrol Union and the
Sheriff's Department posted Alana's
coerced apology to their Facebook pages
and rod Ponton personally rebuked the
Alpine avalanches reporting of the raid
well the DEA did come to the paper and
he wanted to talk to me about what was
wrong with my article he said
specifically he was not there to
threaten me which is an odd thing to her
from the DEA rather he was emphasizing
that I didn't seem to understand how bad
synthetic drugs were at one point Ponton
told me the problem with the story was
that I tried to tell both sides in his
opinion Alip students were not credible
sources and at that point the DEA told
me that he had contacts the papers
owners the owner edited and rewrote much
of the follow-up story that ran the week
after where we had tried to tell both
sides of the story the first time it was
the law enforcement version of the story
that was doing the second time it had
been so heavily edited in so many hands
had touched it that I had asked it my
byline be removed in that didn't happen
the outside avalanche in all the papers
owned by the same parent company include
a tagline thank a veteran a member of
our armed services or a law enforcement
officer every day Ponton declined our
request for an interview but released a
statement declaring that the Alpine PD
had seized Spice from the purple zone in
previous raids which he blamed for
alpine residents stealing a car and
killing himself while high on a drug
that is quote worse than meth similar to
cocaine meth or heroin all of the
products that they seized in the 2014
raid came back from the labs as being
negative of any thing no substances were
found they were all herbs people who
always come in and ask me the strangest
questions like can I smoke this in a
pipe or you know just you know they will
just get me really high and you know I
need you I immediately look at these
people and I'd be like you need to get
out of my store I really think that I
probably threw out more people than I
sold to now we've seen from documents
provided by the district attorney that
there were dozens of attempted DEA buys
what they thought were controlled
substances but which turned up nothing
right right the list said you know DEA
buy do you buy on all the different
dates and and all the things that they
bought were either kratom or tobacco
alternative herbs that you know came in
bags and so yeah they they harassed me a
lot a lot Alanna traces the relentless
hostility from law enforcement back to
when she first arrived in Alpine as an
18 year old equine science major at
Sloan Ross University a mutual
acquaintance introduced Alana to a local
lawyer who shared her interest in
Arabian horses
his name was Rod Pun he had invited me
to meet his horses you know at his house
and possibly work with them you know so
I thought oh job opportunity you know
this is this is great ya asked me if I
wanted to drink some wine and of course
I said yes
you know bottled wine later I was a
little tipsy and one thing led to
another and I was involved sexually with
him at one time and before that he had
offered the P side you know you'd made
such a nice breakthrough with these
horses do you want do you want these
sources the few times after that it was
really it was just kind of hey you know
let's sign the papers over to me and
really never responded back to his phone
calls and I was really disgusted with
myself and and I remember being outside
on my property and seeing his car drive
by really slowly you know
it was almost like as if he was stalking
me that was so many years ago and I
didn't really think that not calling
someone back would trouble rod Ponton
was elected Alpine's District Attorney
in 2012 and since that time has crusaded
against the purple zone in one court
motion he referred to Alana's singular
incorrigibility and accused her of
poisoning the youth of the town I mean
she wasn't breaking the law as the test
approvement she wasn't doing anything
wrong and they just chose this stance I
mean just to prove a point and and I
think that's really a troubling thing
for you know me not just hear an outline
but in our society in general we see it
all over yeah there's no reason for a
militarized radar smoke shop I mean this
is something they could have handled in
a non-confrontational nonviolent fashion
and they chose to come in and break the
door down I mean I've seen the security
footage and they're coming in action
movie style the main reason I took the
pictures and didn't back down on this
because they I just feel like it's
something that needs to be document it
needs to be out the public sphere and
there has to be a discussion on this in
September the federal government
dismissed all charges against Alana and
her sister from the 2014 raid but Alana
pled guilty to state charges of felony
possession of a controlled substance in
exchange for her plea the charges
against her mother were dropped and as a
deferred adjudication the case goes away
without a conviction if Alana completes
probation why would Alana plead guilty
to selling controlled substances that
were not illegal at the time of her
arrest perhaps to save her mother and
sister from prison perhaps to avoid
prison herself
perhaps because fighting these charges
has cost her more than a hundred
thousand dollars in legal fees and lost
property as part of the plea agreement
Alana is free to leave Alpine which he
plans to do as soon as possible
made a lot of good friends here love the
area it's beautiful but it's it's become
toxic I never wanted to aggravate
anybody I mean I've just I don't do this
for fun this isn't a hobby this is how I
make my money this is how I support
myself this is how this is how I live
and any freedom-loving person needs to
take pause and say could this happen to
me if I was unpopular I mean yes you
have a business that's unpopular with a
certain segment of the community and
that shouldn't cause a bias as far as
your freedom is concerned nobody has the
ability to fight the government for too
long